well one thing I do know that the 2008
presidential election is going to be my
opinion one of the most important
elections we've had in this country in a
long long time we have no no vice
president who's automatically the
nominee we have no no frontrunner
surefire nominee at this point
everything is on the table and we have a
wide variety of candidates on but in
both parties plus a possibility of an
independent candidacy or two we have an
opportunity to and we have time this
campaign people are complaining about
how long the campaign is I think that's
a terrific thing everybody gets tested
everybody gets known so we won't you
know that increases the chances of our
not making a mistake if we know when we
go through this blown long involved
process that some people find boring i
don't find boring at all how long the
world can it be boring 24 in a for a
campaign that's going to lead in the
election of the President of the United
States biggest issue everybody's a rote
knee-jerk education is a big issue well
now if it's such a big issue why are we
fixing that there's not one thing in the
way we have all the resources with the
United States of America could educate
every child in America beautifully but
with that without even thinking about it
we have that we have the resource we
have the people or smart enough to do it
and then forgotten God knows we have the
reason because educated people tend to
be better citizens better everything and
and it really does raise all the votes
and all of that and so very optimistic
right now but I'm optimistic most of the
time and I'm optimistic right now this
because this election that doesn't
anything to do with george w bush and
everything to do with what happens
what's happened before we've got to set
its difficult circumstances right now
and I'm I am hopeful that this process
we're going to go through to elected a
new president is going to help get on
top
you